for the second time in a week A Bank in
crisis and markets on the edge after the
collapse of Silicon Valley Bank credit
Suites a far larger institution bailed
out by the Swiss Central Bank which
offered a 44 billion pound credit line
overnight to calm Global markets
its largest shareholder said there was
no need for alarm they were very well
capitalized I think if you look at what
even the Swiss Central Bank said
yesterday is that we've looked at all
the ratios they're all sound everything
is fine yeah I don't think they'll need
more capital I think the markets are
very skittish and they're looking for
for stories the investment bank has long
been subject to allegations of tax
evasion money laundering and corporate
Espionage and lost billions in high
profile collapses what concerns
regulators and markets is the risk of
contagion in the banking system as
interest rates rise we've got that dual
pronged issue of central banks trying to
fight an inflationary problem that's
been building over the last couple of
years that's suddenly been knocked
sideways by what potentially could have
been in quite a crisis of confidence in
the banking system and of course
confidence is the Bedrock of banking
activity the European Central Bank
raised interest rates by half a
percentage Point despite concerns we are
monitoring current market tensions
closely
We Stand ready to respond as necessary
to preserve price stability and
financial stability in the Euro area
and they're watching closely here the
bank of England is monitoring The
Fallout from Credit Suisse and says the
system here is much more robust than
before the financial crisis but it will
give them something else to think about
when they consider whether to raise
interest rates next week because the
central banks around the world have
pushed up rates to tackle inflation it's
exposed Institutions and investors we
saw it here with the pensions market
after the mini budget the problem for
Regulators is they can't know where
these land mines are buried and when or
if they'll go off
seven seismic days for banking began
with the fall of Silicon Valley Bank
HSBC which brought its British arm for a
pound says consumers can have confidence
banks in the UK are on a very different
place and that's where you've got to
really congratulate good strong
regulation I know sometimes complain
about it but it's good and here we are
now we're in a safe place banks are very
well capitalized great liquidity pools I
I think it's very different from 2008.
is the financial system adjusts to a new
normal this is unlikely to be the last
spasm of concern Paul Kelso Sky News in
the city of London